hi I'm Ryan Wright and I'm a shouty of
fun for Jerry welcome two reasons to see
where we give you reasons to see and not
to see that's me
so let's hang out on sport reason to see
number one Leonardo DiCaprio DiCaprio is
the reason to see this [ __ ] movie I
would recommend this movie just off of
him alone
I think DiCaprio is the [ __ ] the edify
Gatsby for so long before he finally
shows up on screen and the split second
that he finally appears you're like I
know what everyone's talking about based
off the way you're coming across and
your smile and everything about you
you're just his life he embodies this
guy the Great Gatsby is one of my
favorite books and when I found out that
Leo DiCaprio was gonna be playing Gatsby
I was like oh my god he is perfect
I couldn't imagine anyone else playing
the role and I'm really glad that he
absolutely delivered on my expectations
they talk a lot about Gatsby being very
hopeful and there is a sense of like
boyish type of hopefulness inside of
this guy and at the same time he's got
the swag down and everything is the easy
is just he is the [ __ ] the bottom line
of this like as far as I feel about the
movie I don't find it to be that great
but the moves called The Great Gatsby
and how is DiCaprio's Gatsby
well he goes beyond great in this way
he's amazing reason to see number two
Tobey Maguire something requires good in
this film I don't think he's great I
don't think he's like the one of his
exceptional standout performances I will
say those scenes between him and
DiCaprio are very very good that great
chemistry yeah I know they've been
friends for many many years since I
think they're like their teen years or
something like that and that type of
camaraderie really does show in this
movie because I don't want to say it
seems a little homoerotic to me I know
it's got a homosexual at first he's like
you're gonna have anything you want
anything I don't think I don't know you
sexual though I just felt like Gatsby he
struggled and you know with
to be wealthy and he sees this guy make
who's just a really upstanding guy who
is kind of low on the totem pole and
it's trying to help him out and be an
inspiration for him be kind of like be
his mentor take him under his wing I
didn't see it as the homoerotic that's
what you got yeah that's how you kind of
get from the book to a mentorship yeah
what a mentorship I don't see that at
all in this movie well of course yes
because Nick is Daisy's cousin but at
the same time is it why else would he
have interest in him to take him under
it why why he doesn't even know the guy
and he's like here you could fly around
on my plane he's making us good guy and
he has Chuck that of course he has
alternative motives or he you know wants
to kind of use Nick together use Nick
but that does not mean that he doesn't
establish a genuine friendship with Nick
because he Nick becomes his collar it
was a homoerotic relationship that Nick
rhyme with it everyone knows what Nick
rhymes with you know I think that I'm
just gonna take my innocent little self
here and he lets everyone come to his
party and he gives one invitation to his
next story because Nick doesn't go to
the parties but he's always curious
about the parties like he's just kind of
china-us time going off the book are you
going off the movie though I think
you're going off the book more than you
are the movie is in this movie it
certainly came across but you know what
that's just that's fine reason to see
number three Carey Mulligan Carey
Mulligan is a character in this film
that is attractive even even Tobey
Maguire you're probably going to screw
me on this to Tim Maguire seems like he
wants to put his penis on her at first
he does not I'm pretty sure he does you
not see the way he introduces Daisy into
the story
she's beautiful he's like every guy
would stare at her yeah because why
wouldn't she like a lot of guys think
she's attractive I would never describe
my cousin the way Tobey Maguire
described its cousin I remember I just
remember going he wants to have sex when
I was watching the movie that's why I
asked you when we were watching it is
that his cousin because I was a little
concern for the relationship the Caprio
wanted to suck McGuire's dick and
McGuire and anyway Carey Mulligan's in
it she has a really good job and she's
absolutely beautiful I think she's
breathtaking yeah she does a really
great job as Daisy she captures the
character absolutely well she's an
upcoming actress every time I see her in
something I just um it's just taking it
back like wow she's just keep them on
growing and developing into a great
actress
it's a hard character to make likable in
a lot of ways because there's times
you're really not supposed to like her
and there are times where you're really
supposed to be rooting for her it's hard
to find that balance where you'll still
be on board for this character even
though sometimes she's not the most
likeable person breathes Missy number
four Joel Edgerton Joel Edgerton um if
you guys don't know who that is
he plays Tom and you might I know joel
edgerton is a lot of people don't know
who George Inness apparently is in this
movie called warrior and he does a
really good job and I've seen most of
all your edits I see British eyes right
it would be a British person I don't
think he is British but anyway II just
really good job he's essentially plays
the villain in this film he's like the
perfect opposite of Gatsby in this movie
agonist yeah yeah okay
whereas Gatsby goes more for like the
really classy type of guy and portraying
that this guy has a lot more of that
rough sort of American old-school yeah
and you're the perfect the perfect
counterbalance for each other and him in
DiCaprio have not that many scenes
together but the few scenes they have
are some of the best moments and this
play off each other really well like
literally the cast is the reason to see
this movie because when the film takes
the time to slow down and let the
actresses do what they do best that's
when the film is really dynamite that's
when the emotional impact is really
there and there's this one particular
scene that takes place in a hotel which
all entertain DiCaprio that's probably
the best scene in this whole so Joel
Edgerton does an excellent excellent
excellent job to me he's probably to me
even though we put him down on this
fourth on this list 20 the second best
reason to see this movie he has he has a
lot of inner turmoil you can feel all
this repressed [ __ ] that just slowly is
coming out of him as this story
progresses it's like there's greed in
this guy there's even this guy I feel
all that it's a constant inner struggle
with this human being yeah the same time
there's something likable about him
reason to see number 5 production design
love movies that take place during this
time period because I have always been
fascinated with like everything from
like the early 1900s like the 50s this
even bring the 20s back to life in such
a beautiful wave is awesome just to look
at from the costumes to the set pieces
everything's just looked absolutely
fantastic
it makes you want to relive that time
period in a way it kind of makes you
want to go on those parties with those
kinds of guys and live it up the way
they did that see how so the main thing
to do back then was to party it's kind
of crazy because these are older people
and it's like let's not many people do
this these days but my point is that you
based on you get so immersed into that
lifestyle it's like you want to be part
of the personality you want to be part
of the style you want to be part of just
the overall environment reasons not to
see their writing and directing while
this film certainly has its moments
where there's greatness it constantly
goes back and forth between rush rush
rush rush rush information information
random visual scenes and there's just a
whole bunch of crap and then let's slow
down and have them
greatness it's not consistent and that's
something yes there's a lot of major
tonal inconsistencies and especially
like DiCaprio doesn't come in something
maybe like 15 20 minutes into the film
and everything before DiCaprio shows up
is just a shitload of visuals and a lot
of information and it's like literally
just the editing is out of control you
don't really know what's going on and
you just hear a narration and scenes of
dialogue whether they're showing other
[ __ ] going on while people are talking
it's really has a lack of focus it's
like they didn't know what this movie
wanted to be about that they want it to
be about feeling like they're back in
the 20s that it wanted to be about the
characters what was the what was the
message that we're trying to convey I
felt like the filmmakers didn't know
what I never read the book but I felt
like they did themselves didn't fully
understand what this book was about and
I've heard that people say oh I guess
it's the Gatsby great gatsby is just a
really hard book - exactly - movie you
know honestly I don't think that it was
that it's that hard I mean okay I'm not
a movie maker or anything but I feel
like this movie had potential to be
amazing be excellent right on par and
because of this inconsistency it just
just blew it what what I think about it
is Baz Luhrmann the director of this
film he if he just held back a little
bit cuz this film is very much extreme
in terms of trying to bombard it with a
shitload of energy didn't mean that and
if he held back just a tiny bit you know
like when actors are talking if he they
just if you left the camera on the
actors rather than cutting around to a
bunch of other weird [ __ ] that's going
on it would have been that much better
like it's all there all the ingredients
are there but if the director just
decided to hold back a little bit they
would have had a very very solid foam
instead of having such a split audience
about it split decisions the visual
effects this is a split decision not
because we necessarily disagree but
because the visual effects may become
very distracting after a certain point
which is kind of early on like they look
good
they look amazing but it's bombarded
like that is the work for it what's so
annoying because I just wanted to like
just take off like a lens so I could see
it clearly because I just kept getting
so distracted by these fancy shots fancy
camera angles fancy this fancy that and
it was that the most inappropriate so
unnecessary honestly I think you didn't
feel this way but Gatsby's house to me
it was obviously computer-generated and
it was so obvious to me that it was
distracting yeah inside was beautiful
inside was not that was that looked like
it either a real house or set it looked
authentic but that outside looked really
computer-generated and I did not like
that it was super distracting every time
we saw the outside I was just like I
feel like I'm playing a video game right
now
it's nothing something doesn't have
substance it's just there's
significantly more style than substance
in this film gets lost in this style
yeah let me just flash it at you and it
was like just shut the [ __ ] up and let
me watch the damn it's like later in the
movie
I don't need this veneer that you're
trying to show off who Ryan's consensus
Leonardo DiCaprio is the main reason to
see the Great Gatsby Leonardo DiCaprio
is the main reason to see the Great
Gatsby
honestly it's called the Great Gatsby
and DiCaprio is beyond great Michels
consensus there are some reasons to see
the Great Gatsby there are some reasons
to see the Great Gatsby
you know I love the cast and that's
pretty much it alright guys thanks for
checking out our show why don't you go
ahead scroll that comment box below and
tell us what you thought of the Great
Gatsby how it compared to the book and
if is this the best remake they've done
a phenomenal tell us below and if you
would like to see more episodes of
reasons to see click the link right here
and if you want to see my straight
to-the-point review of Great Gatsby
click the link right here and laugh
at least remember - sorry wow you're
really excited about telling the
audience to subscribe it love you guys
so much people to subscribe subscribe to
my friends yeah yeah sure funny they're
sexy they got big dicks you can wear
sexy movie critics with big dicks that's
what you don't know that there's so that
you can see it mmm they walk around
something yeah there we go
especially when were naked oh yeah
that's the best we started doing these
reviews naked oh yeah it's the warm-up
you know yeah cuz we were like how do we
get it comfortable with each other as
possible and so we did it in the nude
and it was fine and then yeah yeah it
was great
you